Russian President Vladimir Putin is now
saying that he and Donald Trump speak
quote regularly on the phone
Vladimir Putin said this during an
interview with Austrian television
station Oh RF do we believe it I don't
know I mean I'm curious whether Sean
Hannity participates in the phone calls
I know he puts Trump to bed via phone
many many nights of the week I don't
know if it's true if it's true that
Putin and Trump are regularly speaking
on the phone it would be notable because
there are no real reports of regular
phone calls between Trump and Putin I
think there's been about a call a month
reported over the last several months
but Putin's goal in supporting Trump in
2016 wasn't all about Trump specifically
right it was about creating chaos and a
way to create chaos is to claim that you
regularly speak to Donald Trump this
despite the fact that the White House
doesn't seem to be logging the fact that
Donald Trump and Putin are regularly
speaking so if Putin is telling the
truth it fits into this sort of bizarre
Russia situation where there's a
constant effort to hide the truth about
contacts with Russia and if Putin is
lying then it's a page straight out of
Alexander Duggan's 1997 classic book
foundations of geopolitics which
specifically recommends that what Russia
should do with regard to Western
democracies is to do anything they can
to create chaos to create internal
racial strife to create circumstances
that make people question whether
democracy is sort of working properly or
as designed and even if not true even if
it's easily disprovable that Trump and
Putin are speaking regularly it's still
going to help rile people up right Putin
is smart Putin knows exactly how to stir
the pot and the truth is that Russian
collusion or not there would be some
contact between Trump and Putin because
there are world leaders right so then it
becomes a matter of degree and a matter
of optics if there were truly continuing
to be sketchy contacts between the Trump
team and Russia you would imagine that
they would be using some kind of
back-channel maybe not the failed
back-channel that Jared Kushner tried to
set up but no doubt there would be
others there were multiple attempts to
backchannels we learned about the
Kushner back-channel attempt the
Seychelles Islands back-channel attempt
and even if the communication that were
of concern were between Trump and Putin
directly there could be off the record
calls period so I believe the most
likely scenario here is that there are
Trump intermediary with Putin
intermediary calls for the purposes of
plausible deniability and that's if
they're dumb enough to continue
coordinating and they may well be from
what we've been seeing but the more we
learn about this relationship between
Putin and Trump the more it's clear that
loyalty is just not a factor here right
Putin isn't loyal to Trump Putin saw
Trump as a tool to sow chaos in American
democracy and it worked and as soon as
Putin benefits from trying to hurt Trump
or to make Trump look bad or stupid he's
going to do it and in some ways he's
already started and at the same line
along the same lines Pat Trump's not
loyal to Putin either right he seems
sort of enamored with Putin's power he
seems to admire a lot of these
authoritarian dictatorial types turkish
president air Dewan Xi Jinping's Xi
Jinping's
elimination of term limits in China I
don't think there's a really a matter of
loyalty here one way or the other but I
still want to know if they're talking to
one another regularly it reminds me of
when Alex Jones claimed that he talks to
the president now and again yeah like
you can't trust either party so who
knows who's telling the truth and you
can't even go to the White House press
secretary and ask about it because Sarah
Huckabee Sanders would probably answer
that question with something like oh
well the president likes to talk with
foreign leaders all the time and we
wouldn't get a straight answer from her
she'll say no you know that's a question
that really relates to technology and
phone companies because if they were
speaking by phone a phone was used so it
doesn't really relate to the White House
you'd have to ask the phone companies
about something like that let me know do
you think Trump and Putin speak
regularly or do you think this is more
crafty calculation from Putin merely to
create even more chaos we do have a
david pakman show subreddit where you
can discuss this and any other stories
of interest david pakman.com slash
ar e d di T we will take a very brief
pause and be back very shortly today's
program is made possible in part by
Warby Parker eyeglasses which I now have
two pairs of Warby Parker offers a free
five day in-home trial of their glasses
you try five pairs you see which you
like I wear contact lenses on the show
but I often wear glasses at night and on
weekends and both of my pairs of Warby
Parker glasses are great I did the free
at-home trial
I picked five frames that I liked on
their website they sent them to me I
picked the one I liked the most sent
them back typed in my prescription
online and soon I got my finished
glasses with my prescription in the mail
and I love this because when I'm at a
glasses store trying on glasses I can't
really figure out if I like them because
I feel the pressure of the salespersons
gaze on me I want to show the glasses to
other people I need time to figure out
which glasses I want to commit to and
the eyeglass industry is also controlled
by a tiny number of companies which
keeps prices very high I even know
people who have spent over three hundred
dollars for a pair of glasses but with
Warby Parker there start at just ninety
five dollars that's what mine cost to
try the five pairs and support the David
Pakman show go to war V Parker trial
comm /t DPS